if you're out there playing free  basketball by yourself step up for your  brother tonight  defense me fence first of all you're  wrong  i'm not wrong shaq they got 73 points  they're on poster they don't pay for 140  bro i don't care how many points you got  as long as you win the game y'all  everybody got to step up but first of  all  first of all i speak from not being a  great defensive player but having  championship experience i know what the  hell i'm talking about  the others got to step up period i don't  give a damn what you're talking about  hey listen listen  rob hook me up rob hey listen let me  tell you hit me up rob  they got a big shot bob i appreciate you  bishop roberto jason uh  uh james posey don't forget when i got  double triple teams  i'm getting caught with away carrying  your fat ass talking so listen  they got to play some defense like he  said they  gave up 70 points to a team that's  missing rob hook me up probably is five  four or five best players